quand vous étiez petit votre idole
c'était Achille Zavatta ouais c'est vrai
et maintenant c'est François Hollande
mais
pas mieux
avec nous ce soir Pierre Lescure
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
président de Canal+ et vous êtes ici ce
soir pour nous annoncer que vu
qu'Antoine de Caunes revient vous aussi
vous voulez bien revenir
j'espère qu'ils ont pas changé les
serrures
bonsoir alors j'ai dit si ce soir parce
qu'après avoir créé Canal+ Sport Canal+
Family et Canal+ série le groupe a
décidé de créer Canal+ arthrose
comme vous le savez pierre Canal+ tient
beaucoup au nombre de canal historique
les morceaux de la vraie croix il y a
Groland il y avait Denisot bientôt de
Caunes il faut que survive le fameux
esprit canal d'abord j'ai jamais très
bien su ce qui était l'esprit canal je
pense qu'on a eu le mérite de remplir
une page blanche et de ne pas retenir le
stylo de se laisser aller de pouvoir
presque tout essayer donc ça a créé un
certain esprit de curiosité de novation
et de liberté l'esprit canal en fait
c'est un peu comme l'ingrédient secret
dans le Coca-Cola
on est pas sûr que ça existe mais tout
le monde y croit en fait exactement mais
c'est pour ça c'est bien de continuer à
l'arroser un peu voilà mais c'était pas
la coque l'esprit canal
mais non mais si c'est pour une raison
simple
si les gens avaient bossé autant
simplement avec ce carburant là il
serait tous morts ou la majorité
aujourd'hui si on a 30 ans ça veut dire
qu'il y a plein de gens de mon âge qui
comme vous nous portons très bien
alors vous avez vu pierre que Michel
Denisot arrête il quitte canal vous
pensiez pas voir ça votre vivant en fait
non lui non plus mais en même temps
c'est vrai que quitter canal et huit
jours plus tard lancer valides
est de retour sur Canal mais pas peur
que ça lui fasse un peu bizarre de
découvrir les études marketing les
mesures d'impact des vannes sur les
cibles 15-34 tout ça c'est pas à la fois
il est fédérateur mais c'est pas un
consensus mou il a toujours terriblement
travaillé vous aimez ça tout est
toujours tenu et en même temps il y a de
la liberté en plus il a il a un truc qui
m'exaspère c'est sa jeunesse il a
quasiment 60 ans
alors pierre vous êtes amis avec
François Hollande depuis 30 ans c'est
pas un peu long parce que moi ça fait un
an déjà
non non je le connais bien puis on sait
surtout vu sur le plan privé avec des
tas de gens des tas de copains vous
voyez au théâtre on se voyait pour le
plaisir et vous savez bien qu'il est de
commerce extrêmement agréable donc
l'amitié se cultive bien avec lui alors
François Hollande nous a confié une
mission une mission délicate car l'un
des objectifs de cette mission était de
restaurer la confiance entre le pouvoir
politique et les milieux culturels le
bilan d'adopie c'est vrai que c'est
quand même pas énorme quoi en deux ans
et demi de surveillance il y a eu deux
condamnations et c'est quand même une
organisation qui coûte chaque année au
contribuable 12 millions d'euros je suis
d'accord sur le coup excessif pour le
service rendu mais il y a un service de
la depuis qui a très bien fonctionné
c'est ce qu'on appelle la riposte
graduée ils ont envoyé plus de 2
millions et demi un courrier en première
avertissement à 95% il n'y a pas eu
récidive c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu deux
condamnations dans votre rapport vous
préconisez de conserver le principe de
la sanction mais en remplaçant la
coupure de l'accès Internet par une
amende et de confier les fonctions
d'adopi au CSA ça c'est du vrai Hollande
un certain nombre
est content quoi on se fasse avec
personne c'est tout oui mais on peut le
prendre comme ça moi je peux le prendre
de façon plus raisonnable on n'allait
pas conserver une autorité
administrative indépendante qui coûte si
cher pour seulement la riposte parce que
ça ça coûte déjà beaucoup de blé il faut
le dire oui mais les CSA j'en suis
convaincu va prendre de plus en plus
d'importance à l'avenir alors le milieu
culturel sont assurés puisque donc il y
a pas de licence globale les pirates
sont rassurés parce que l'amande elle
est 60 euros donc tout le monde coûtera
plus cher en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
propose non non ça peut monter pas loin
de 1000 alors est-ce que vous avez
impliqué cloud serions le conseiller en
communication de François Hollande dans
cette réflexion et ben pas du tout vous
avez eu raison parce qu'en fait c'est un
visionnaire le mec
au moment du lancement de Canal+ il
avait dit André Rousselet une télé
payante ça ne peut pas marcher et
surtout c'est scandaleux de faire payer
la télé quand même
comme je suis petit votre idole c'était
Achille avatars et maintenant c'est
François Hollande
mais
pas mieux j'ai pas mieux
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu